most a century since the tomb of Egypt's
King Tut was discovered nearly intact
since then most of the tombs treasures
have been secured in museums but the
tomb itself has become a popular tourist
attraction and that's meant plenty of
wear and tear this week Egypt marked a
milestone in the preservation and
protection of the site Roxana Saberi has
the story as the world's most famous
Pharaoh King Tut has attracted millions
of visitors to his tomb but at a cost
dirt decay and scratches on the walls
there's the graffiti so for the past
decade a team led by the LA based Getty
conservation Institute has been hard at
work renovating the more than 3,300 year
old crypt it's the first major
renovation since the 1920s when British
archaeologist Howard Carter discovered
the site in Egypt's Valley of the Kings
as King Tut turned into an international
sensation tourists strong to his tomb to
see the sarcophagus and mummy of King
Tut himself the conservators have
cleaned and restored the painting
showing the life and death of the
Pharaoh while leaving these spots caused
by fungus that's no longer spreading it
is impossible to remove the brown spots
without damaging the paintings so for us
there's there's no question we cannot
remove them they have also put in
barriers and added a new ventilation
system to reduce moisture and dust
during most of the repairs that tomb has
stayed open but work was delayed by the
Arab Spring in 2011 with the political
upheaval came violence and a collapse of
Egypt's tourism industry Egyptian
officials hope tourists will return now
that King Tut's tomb has returned to its
ancient splendor for CBS this morning
Saturday Roxana Saberi London
interesting tourists breath are part of
the problem in the two minutes it's
amazing to walk in there it is just
it's your in another time you really are
well hope you all can visit one day